تحذير امامي من تحول الوضع في السودان
لازمه اقليميه محكمه فرنسيه تقضي بسجن
نيكولا ساكوزي بقضيه فساد واشنطن ترصد
عشره ملايين دولار لاعتقال قرصان روسي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بالتزامن مع استمرار الاشتباكات في
السودان حذرت الامم المتحده من ان الوضع
في البلاد يتحول الى ازمه اقليميه بوتيره
سريعه لافته الى انها تتوقع ان يصل عدد
اللاجئين السودانيين هذا العام الى نحو
المليون مدير مكتب الامم المتحده للتنسيق
شؤون الانسانيه في جنيف قال ان نحو 25
مليون شخص يمثلون اكثر من نصف سكان
السودان بحاجه للمساعدات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان الامم المتحده تقدر باكثر من ثلاثه
مليارات دولار حجم المساعدات التي يحتاج
اليها السودان في المجال الانساني
وللاجئين
في خطوه غير مسبوقه لرئيس فرنسيا سابق قضت
محكمه السنافر في باريس بسجن الرئيس
الاسبق نيكولا ساخكوزي ثلاث سنوات واحده
منها مع النفاذ بعد ادانته بالفساد
واستغلال النفوس المحكمه قررت ايضا حرمان
نسخ كوزيل 3 سنوات من حقوقه المدنيه مما
يجعله غير مؤهل لاي انتخابات مشيره الى
انه سيرتدي سوارا الكترونيا بدلا من دخول
السجن في السنه الثالثه وياتي هذا القرار
بعدما خسر ساركوزي استئنافه ضد حكما
بالسجن في عام 2021 لما اعلنت محاميته
انها ستتقدم بطعن جديدا امام محكمه النقد
الى عمان حيث اعلنت شركه الطيران العماني
تاجيل رحله عائده من شيراز في ايران الى
العاصمه مسقط بعد تعرض طائره المدنيه
لاضرار بسبب اجسام غريبه اثناء الهبوط على
مدرج مطار شيراز الدولي الحادث ترتب عليه
تاخير اقلاع رحله طيران تلك فيما اوضح تيل
الشركه في بيان ان فريقا من مهندسي الشركه
سوف يقوم حاليا بالاجراءات اللازمه لاعاده
الطائره بامان الى عمان وتابعت انها ارسلت
طائره بديله الى شيراز لنقل المسافرين الى
مسقط
عشره ملايين دولار مكافاه رصدتها الولايات
المتحده لمن يزودها بمعلومات تقودها الى
توقيف وادانت هاكر روسي متهم بالوقوف خلف
هجمات استهدفت الشرطه واشنطن ومدارس
ومستشفياته
الامريكيه اوضحت في بيان ان ميخائيل متهم
باستخدام برامج فنيه الكترونيه لمهاجمه
اهداف في الولايات المتحده بندخل روسيا
بقصد الحصول من ضحاياه على فديه ماليه تصل
قيمتها الاجماليه الى 200 مليون دولار
فيما كان رد ميخائيل بانه لا يبالي
بالاعلان الامريكي
في خبرنا الاخير رد رئيس التنفيذي لشركه
مايكروسوفت نادل على اتهامات ايلون ماسك
التي قال فيها ان مايكروسوفت تتحكم
ببرنامج
لا تسيطر على اوبن اي اي المبتكره لبرنامج
تشاتشي وان الاخيره لها مجلس اداره مستقل
مشيرا الى ان هذا المجلس هو المتحكم في
شركتهم على عكس ماسك الذي انسحب من الشركه
المنافسه منذ سنوات
وايضا
دعا الى ابطاء تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي
بسبب المخاوف الاخلاقيه المحتمله وفقا لما
نقلته وكاله بلومبريك